it I don't think so first of all I would
like I would like to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to speak here and I must say I was
thinking a lot whether I should speak
about finite forcibility but I had a
feeling I spoke on red topic a lot so
many of you have had me talk about it
and I decided to to speak about the
Quasi Randomness and the interaction of
Baza Randomness with combinator limits
so there will be graph limits but there
will be also limits of other combinator
objects and I should say that I will be
focusing mostly on the results when the
theory of graph limits actually had
an impact on the proof so with most of
the proofs even if I will not present
them where like coming from the theory
of community limits and I will not be
mentioning
excellent some recent work on how to
Define quasi Randomness in various
settings due to koreani and rasporov and
I will also not mentioned results very
many which are not like so much related
to the combinator limits which existed
before in particle to the typographic
randomness was a lot of work because it
can be defined like the various uh you
know various degrees of classy
Randomness but I want to mostly focus on
the interaction of of combinator limits
and Crossing Randomness but I will break
my promise already on the first slide
because I want to start with an
interaction so I've established some
classical results which actually existed
well before it was a Randomness
before combinator limits and I want to
talk about the results from the
from the early 80s about quasi random
graphs due to due to Chang Graham Wilson
riddle and Thomas
so so what does it so when we speak
about quasi Randomness we want to say
that the particle combinator object
looks like a random one which usually is
not a question which is uh which is a
question about a single object because
let's say we take the address to any
random graph which is the most classical
model for for random graphs so but any
graph can be a result of this process
but we would rather wish to look at a
sequence and we want to say that this
sequence is the properties where the
sequence of graphs which would be
generated by the irritated any random
graph process would have asymptotically
almost sure
so so when I want to speak about the
Quasi random graph I actually don't mean
a single graph but I rather mean a
sequence of graphs if with increasing
orders and the same will be true for for
our combinatorial objects that we will
see during this talk
and as I mentioned the the theory of
Quasi random graph goes to the 80s and
so when I want to save the where the
graph is quasi random so it will be a
property of a sequence and I want to say
that the the density of any graph into
sequence converges to its expected
density in the in the address
and during this talk I will have like
two different densities so one is the
induced density so I let's say hsk
vertices I take a randomly chosen
uniformly cable vertices of G and I'm
looking very mostly vertices induced G
as a sub graph and the other will be the
homomorphic density I take a random
mapping from the vertices of h2g and I I
want to to see what is the probability
but this mapping is homomorphism
and it's not hard to see that actually
if I require that the induced density of
every graph goes to its expected density
then of course the homomorphic density
goes as well as the it is an easy
application of principle of equation and
exclusion and this is the definition of
Quasi random
sequence of graph which is parted out
and it turned out that this notion is a
particularly robust because it's
equivalent to many different properties
most famously right actually instead of
checking this property for all graphs
it's enough to check it for two graphs
so it's enough to check with the density
of edges goes to B because this would be
what would be the expected Edge density
and the homomorphic density of C Force
goes to P to the fourth so if I take a
if I take the energy random graph so I
would require if I take a random mapping
with the cyclically ordered vertices
will map to to C4 and this will happen
with probability po p to the four
so I kind of prepared here some some
pictures so instead of checking all
graphs one can check an edge and and C4
but this is actually I can't do many
other properties so for example if I
take an N vertex subset where n is uh
not the total number of vertices was
linear into the number of vertices well
the number of edges on that subset will
be roughly the expected Edge that's it
so I can take a linear size subset of
vertices and look what is this Edge
density and if the H density on every
linear size subset of vertices is what
one would expect it to be when
all the free previous properties also
called and vice versa
instead of looking on the number of
edges inside I can take two two random
let's say this joint subset again linear
size look at the number of edges between
and again this is equivalent to all the
previous properties and I can also look
at uh at the Specter properties so I can
look what is the adjacency Matrix let's
say now n is the number of vertices of
My Graph so I expect the largest
eigenvalue to be P times n because I
expected My Graph will be roughly P
times and regular of course it won't be
exactly regular but but close to and I
expect all the either eigen values to be
to be sub linear and by many other but
Live password they do mention these five
and this kind of that shows that this is
a very very robust notion because this
this one definition is actually
equivalent to many others
and now let me because this is a
workshop on computer limits now let me
cast some of these results in terms of
of uh of uh of combinator limits and to
do that let me let me actually introduce
the notion of of graph limits and where
analytic representation which is called
the graph phone even if I assume that
most of you have seen it but let me
still quickly go through through this
notion
so first of all I want to say that a
sequence of grasses conversion if the
densities of sub graphs converges I have
chosen here the homomorphic density but
of course if the homomorphic density of
every subgraph converges again an easy
application of principle of inclusion
exclusion is that the induced densities
also do converge and then
and in this in this uh in this
definition quasi random means when the
sequence is a sequence of graphs is
quasi random if it's conversion and the
limit of it of every density is the
expected density in the in the in the
attrition
and every convergent sequence that's a
result by by lovas and sagari is X can
be represented by by a graphone which is
a symmetric measurable function from the
unit Square to a unit interval and
and the kind of the naive view of
graphone can be as a as a continuous
version of adjacent symmetrices but I
should say this is a huge
oversimplification but let me let me
still sell it as a continuous version of
a adjacency metrics and I prepare here
an illustration so if I take a sequence
of graphs which are complete bipartite
graphs with the number of vertices in
the ratio one to two and this would be
the adjacency matrices and then the
limit will be this graph form so the
origin is in the top left corner to to
make the analogy with the adjacency
matrices these two parts will be zero
and these two parts will be one to
represent the edges between the parts
but it's possible to define the
homomorphic density of a graph in a
graphone so so Yvonne run things like
how would one compute this for an
adjacency Matrix it will be like a sum
overall vertices and then zero ones and
one replaces the sum with an integer and
gets a definition for a graph phone and
it actually works very well and I
prepare here pictures of some other
graphones so this one is the complete
bipartite graph with parts of equal
sizes this one is actually the graph one
which is constantly equal to p and this
is the graph one that actually
represents the sequence of Quasi random
graphs because we expect no structure we
just expect the edges to be uniformly
distributed which is exactly one of the
conditions that I have shown here
and this graphone is the graphone where
I have a click on how vertices water 1 8
and so on so as the end would be growing
I will see Greeks and one of them will
be on one on half of the vertices of one
and a quarter and so on
so let me now
the the previous result in in the
language of graph limit so so so a
sequence of graphs is closer random if
and only if the the limit is even half
or B depends like how we review it and
uh and then this is what what is the the
result on the C4 and K2 to cast in the
language of graph limit so if I have a
graph on W demomorphic density of K2 is
p the homomorphic density of C4 is p to
the four when that graphene is is equal
to P almost everywhere
what I want to do during this talk so
this result existed before the theory of
combinator limits I want to present
various results of this type but
actually the theory of combinator limits
provided suitable tools for proofing
and I just want to mention when this
actually implies also this but maybe let
me in the interest of time since we
already like and maybe let me just skip
commenting on this
so I want to to mention some some
various results but let me stay a little
bit longer with uh with with graph forms
and I want to mention a particle step
graph phones so a step graph phone is a
graphone where vertices can be or the
the interval can be partitioned into
into subsets and to finitely many
subsets that the the value of a grapher
for if I if I fix one part and another
part on one part response term so this
is also called the stochastic block
model
and uh one of the early results in the
theory of graph limit is due to lavas
and shosh and they showed that if uh
when the case step grapher is actually
characterized by by densities of some
graphs of these many vertices so we had
like uh in the case of one step it we we
knew that we checked the density of K2
and C4 when this captures the the
forces the the graphone to be constant
and when they generalize this but
instead of having one party one FK parts
then these many vertices will suffice
and then this actually was improved by
by lovers that actually a polynomial
number of vertices is enough
and uh and then of course the question
comes over this is Optima and I want to
sell here a recent result but I have if
uh answer exactly cannot like which
actually shows that this polynomial can
be brought down to to quadratic
unfortunately we were trying to prove a
lower bound and uh besides the rather
easy linear lower bound we don't know
whether this is optimal so so perhaps
like this can be brought down to linear
but maybe maybe quadratic is the right
and of course likewise actually better
results in case one assumes very
Advantage the row integral kind of the
degree if it is different for parts
and uh and Spencer actually showed that
linear is enough in case the degrees of
parts are different
and our methods actually improve this
too from 8K to to 2K plus one
I wanted to make this a slight detour
just to show it in first of all
mentioned some very recent results
like just two weeks old and also like to
to mention that one can not only
consider like quasi Randomness in the in
the very classical sense but also
consider more General Notions like the
like this
so let me now switch to so to other type
of of combinator object namely a
tournament
so a tour Ramen is just an orientation
of a complete graph so I could hear some
some pictures these two are actually
transitive tournaments which means that
working all the vertices in a way that
all the edges go from a smaller vertex
to a larger vertex so this is a
transitive to nominal fiber it is a
transitive tournamental six vertices and
again where X is an analytic
representation which is called the
tournament on
it's a it's a measurable function from
the unit Square to unit interval but
instead of the symmetric condition one
has this uh this complementary sum
condition which somehow represents that
one has an achiever in one or the other
direction or sometimes the the density
of edges is uh it's uh like basically
it's kind of captures but the the
regularity partition would give
so in particle this tournament is a
representation of a sequence of of
transitive tournamentals this one
corresponds to the random one we see no
structure the edges go in both ways and
this is just an example of a little bit
more General tournament concept that I
wanted to do
so now of course the question comes are
there any tournaments tea such that if
the density of a tournament let's say
homomorphic density is what it would be
in the in the in the in in what is the
expected density in a random tournament
which is the other tournament obtained
by randomly oriented digest of complete
graph
so so the question is are there any
tournaments saturated if if in the
tournament or in the sequence of
tournaments one wishes to look at the at
the limit the the density is what one
would expect it to be when the
tournamental must be one half and
actually there are results already from
the 80s that every transitive tournament
with at least K K4 vertices has the
property so this this can be found in
the in the in the lover Facebook
combinatorial exercises and then an
alternative proof using the the flex
algebra method was was given by by
parent and rasborov as one of the the
early or examples of of the early
examples of application of the of the
flight algebra method
so the question is are there any any
fiber the tournament in addition to do
this uh do this uh do this uh do this
transitive tournament
and the answer is yes
so where is this Fiverr text tournament
so which I have just shown here so we
have here two cyclic triangles sharing a
vertex and all edges going from left to
right here so this was proven by
corregliano parente and Sato in 2019
and now once we have an example one
would be hoping that would be infinitely
many so this is actually not the case
which is
no seven vertex uh tournament that would
be forcing quasi randomness
and uh
and very actually like we're studying
also like more more general settings of
of uh of uh quasi Randomness and
tournaments but this is a particular uh
particle color array of one of the
results
and then with Robert Hancock Cabella
in the audience we actually with
children there is no additional
tournament so somehow surprisingly
transitive tournament and this this
special one are the only
only tournaments that capture braziland
of course now one can go with a passive
tournaments or Clippers but even wants
just a single one when these these are
all
and and again these days I was like very
very based on on the on the eye on like
on the analytic representation so
this is a bit counter entity compared to
Jim Ramos and right there I mean if you
have C4 density fc4 or C6 or CA any c2t
would work but here
so
so
the question is that it's why I think
I would actually I mean depends like
because so guys actually an analog of
the C4 and uh I will actually mention it
in maybe not explicitly but I will get
to that on two slides later but uh I
think maybe the counter interism might
come when bug has just one instead of
two but on the other hand there's
nothing like I should have said right
because the agenda said they simply half
so somehow replacing two by one is not
so so counter but neither of these
anyway okay this uh
let me comment on it when I get get I
mean I didn't prepare it but I want to
comment it when I have the proper set up
for it
yeah thanks for requests
so so now I want to do a detour which I
prepared because I found it first of all
is another application of the of the of
the theory of combinator limits but also
like it will like to provide some some
other characterizations of tournaments
and uh but I want to start like
from like a different problem which is
the pro the question about the density
of Cycles in tournaments so if I'm
looking at what is the minimum and
maximum density and I'm considering a
cyclically oriented cycle when the
minimum is easy it's zero because in the
transitive tournament I will not found
find a cycle and the question is what
about the maximum
and clearly I can get at least as
how many how many cycles of line K I can
find in a tournament then let's say I'm
looking in the asymptotic version so I'm
looking at the maximum density and I
want to compare it with the random tour
because if I take a random tournament I
can compute what is the expected density
of cycles of line K so this is clearly
something that I can get and the
question is how better I can get and
this is again a question which was
studied for small K well before
combinator limits I think actually in
the 40s it was it showed that that in
case of of three Cycles it might take a
cyclically oriented triangle then one
cannot do any better somehow
surprisingly for four Cycles I can do
four over three and I will show a
construction in in in a minute and then
some would recently come out of and
Mickey show that for C5 and I can again
not do any better than the random so now
it seems like this might be some pattern
but the question is what is the pattern
and there was a conjecture due to
Barclay and day we I don't think they
made it independently because there were
students at the same University and
their conjunction with CK is one if and
only if K is not divisible by four so so
the pattern would be one then something
larger one one something larger and so
on and they also conjected what the
value should be when K is divisible by
four so they didn't have this formula if
I provided a construction but when one
like lose what is this construction
doing in the limit and looks at the the
limit tournament on when uh when uh
you're just using the inspector
properties like this would be the
formula that comes out
and uh using the
next so using the spectral properties of
tournaments tournament on
we we resolve this problem but before I
get to it I should show you the
construction so the construction of this
uh of for this for this four over three
and also for any K divisible by 4 is the
following so one takes the vertices or
that on a cycle like
and when from each vertex one draws an H
to the to the forward
half heart of the cycle and the edges
from the backward comes to the vertex
and when one rotates so basically every
so vertices are ordered cyclically and
to the to the coming half of the
vertices one has an edge going to an an
incoming Edge from the other so kind of
rotates it around
and even like looks at the limit
tournament on when one can actually look
at its Vector properties link it to the
number of cycles and this will be the
formula one gets
and somewhat surprisingly if K is not
divisible for four one actually this one
does not give anything anything better
sometimes actually gives uh gives less
than one like if in particle if Case
even
I already said that we managed to prove
this first part of the conjecture so
with uh with uh I'm saying
we showed that actually the conjecture
is true so so one can do better if and
only if K is not divisible by 4 and when
we actually showed that we we didn't
prove the conjecture but we showed that
at least the leading tent in this sum is
is what one would expect so we showed
that that the CK is bit if K is
divisible by four it's between two times
two over Pi 2 K which is the leading
time in this sum and it's at most two pi
plus little one two k and we also verify
the conjecture for the next open case
which is C8 which gives three which is
this this fraction we just it the the
value of this of this sum so so it
provides an evidence that this is most
likely the the answer but we were not
able to to prove it for for larger
values okay
but why I talk about it but somewhat uh
surprisingly one of the of the products
of our results is that if K is 2 modulo
four when when we can achieve the
density of Cycles s in the in the in the
random tournament even only if the
spectrum is actually half zero zero zero
so actually the cyclic orientations of
cycles of length six
and likewise the the cyclic orientations
of cycles of length 10 the cyclic
orientation of cycle of length 14 and so
on because it forces the Spectrum and
therefore it forces the tournament
and
and I don't know whether maybe it's now
a good time to to make a detour
and let me try to use a marker which
hopefully is not a permanent marker
and when we were looking at different
orientations
and we actually
and basically the argument is the same
as if one wants to prove the
the Chang Graham and Wilson using
analytic methods when the C4 in the case
of tournaments would be replaced by by
this orientation of a of a of a cycle
so this would be and when the when this
orientation would be quasi random
forcing and then one thinks about it a
little bit further with my title
then
these two vertices
are twins and these two vertices are
twins so it doesn't matter if I find
this orientation in my tournament then
how I Orient The Edge between
environment this is actually a
transitive tournament not four vertices
so this this orientation of C4 which
actually would correspond exactly to
John Graham and Wilson and the proof is
almost the same if one would be proving
it in the language of graphons is uh
is this would be the analog and then the
order for is the the the corresponding
okay so when you in graph from cell
there appears something which well
the physicists would call Perfection
positivity but there is something
but you do some positivity of some kind
of product some how does it work here so
so I mean I'm not trying what I'm
talking about I don't know what you're
talking about and I will be very happy
to discuss during the coffee break but
actually the proof is again like that by
some cautious ones so so I think okay
fine so I would expect the answer is
it's the it's a question yes
so
so now we know like by this result when
the cyclic orientation of C4 is not
quasi random forcing however red
orientation of C4 is so the question is
whether it would be possible to actually
say which orientations are Quasi random
forcing and we thought it would be
rather an easy exercise but basically
one inspect Spectra but it turns out
that it
was quite challenging
so we didn't manage to to do a full
classification we have a full
classification of length up to 12. so
it's a it's a joint work again with uh
I'm saying
who's a student of mine and uh who's a
student of ansay and first of all we
actually showed that no orientation of
an odd cycle is called the random
forcing we have a full characterization
of orientation up to length 12 and and
and I prepared here just with that you
can appreciate what the the
we don't have even a working conjecture
what might be the the orientation so we
have some general theories which covers
most of the cases but in some cases we
needed some ad hoc argument up to length
length 10 it's actually true but if the
if the density
if one checks if One Compares the
density in the transitive tournament and
this special tournament which was
showing for over three if they on the
same side from the random tournament
then it's classy random forcing but
actually it breaks out for the like 12.
and we currently don't have any any
generalization and all these results
were obtained by the analysis of the
Spectra of tournamental so it's again
like a uh like an application of of the
theory of combinator limits
so I think I started like 55 Maybe
yeah I would assume I have still 15
minutes
so so as we now now switch switch a page
so there are two more combinator objects
I want to talk about I want to talk
about permutations and I want to talk
about about Latin scraps and if time
does not permit I will skip the latest
class but I have just two slides on them
so hopefully I will manage
so
so for the permutation I want to Define
again like what is a quasi random
permutation forward I need another a
notion of sub permutation which in the
the Volkswagen with permutations would
actually call the pattern but because I
am trained to be a graph here is I will
be using sub-permutation and I do
apologize to those who who are more from
the permutation work
and rather than a formal definition I
prepare a definition by a picture so
this is this is a large permutation and
I want to look what is a sub permutation
induced by those points which are which
are underlined so I just take them the
smallest one becomes one the second
smallest two the largest is three here's
another example and I should emphasize
here that because I'm a combinatorist
I'm not looking at any algebraic
structure so it's not a mapping for me
I'm not looking at any any signs I'm
just looking at the permutation as two
linear orders one kind of sorting the
elements from left to right the other
one just saying which element is one
which element is to which element is
three
and a natural definition if I have a
sequence of permutations then I will say
it's uh it's quasi random if the density
of every pattern or every sub
permutation tends to 1 over K factorial
which is the number of permutations of
order K and if I take a sequence of
randomly chosen permutations of
increasing order it's positive random
with with probability one
and when Graham
uh and uh the the source is not quite
clear but at some point in the in the in
the 90s ask never actually the same
phenomena that I have been describing
for graphs exist for permutations so
namely everywhere exists k0 saturated
the density of every every permutation
of either k0 goes to 1 over K factorial
which is also implies that the density
of four smaller orders goes to one over
the other factorial whenever this is
this is describing the Quasi randomness
and uh so before I answer that question
so let me Define what is a permutation
limit so so if I have a convergent
sequence of permutations which means the
density of every sub-permutation
converges when the limit which I will be
referring to as a permuton can be viewed
as a probability measure on a unit
square with something which is called
unit marginals so I prepared here a
picture so what do I mean by a unit
marginal so this is my unit square and
when I won but if I take a horizontal
rectangle going from left to right when
it's a measure it's its height and if I
take a vertical rectangle going all the
way from the bottom to the top then it's
measure it is Big so I want kind of if I
project to to the horizontal axis I get
the uniform measure if I project to the
vertical axis I get the the uniform
measure as well so I prepare here some
examples so if I take the measure with
the support on this diagonal that
corresponds to a sequence of increasing
permutations this is a sequence of
decreasing these are like let's say
these are like two sequences which are
increasing let's say I have here like
what points and here I have even points
and this uniform measure will correspond
to the to the to the sequence of random
permutations
and when I can Define like a density of
a small permutation in a permuton which
which I will just Define by taking a
random point so let's say this I prepare
here a picture and then I saw them
according to the x coordinate and when
the Y coordinates the time in what the
points are so this this is the smallest
so becomes one this is the second
largest becomes two absorber and when
one can do a link but for if I have a
conversion sequence of permutation where
X is a permuton such when the problem
with the densities or this probabilities
or the new random permutation of a
particle order is what one would expect
is is this uh is uh is the particle
permutation are actually The Limited
densities of both Supply limitations
so in particular the question now that
Graham was asking is does there exist k0
such very important densities of some
permutations of order k0 are 1 over K
factorial when the measure must be
uniform
and uh
if unlike big worker we actually
answered this question
and be really vacuumed off with with
permutation limits and when it actually
turned out that uh with the the the
access results in statistics which are
related to to Independent tests which
actually are also answering the question
so in particular having in 1948 prove a
result which is actually equivalent to
this statement for k e k 0 equals five
and then in 1970 improved this this uh
this uh this everything's result and
actually essentially proof like this
this equivalence of course using the the
Notions from from statistics
and I just want to mention that k03 is
not sufficient so let me actually
present it now like if I introduce the
language of of permutation limits so let
me present it using the this language
so I take a
I take this this the measure with the if
this supports such when the mess of the
measure is equally distributed along
these two diagonals
and it can be by a direct computation it
can be shown with the density of one two
three in this uh this permuton is one
quarter the density of one two three in
this permuton or well the measure is
like this is the support and again like
equally distributed is 1 8 and now I
take a smooth transformation so I kind
of think of this as two fin rectangle
Stars opening them keep opening them at
some point will become almost square and
once they go inside when is this measure
so at some point during this smooth
transformation I will have a density
which is 1 6 but because this is
symmetric if the density of one two
three is one six the density of three
two one is one six the remaining four
are symmetric to each other the sum of
the densities should be one so the size
in the density of each of them is one
over six so and this is greater than
other unit formation
once we have this result
and of course the question now might
come do we need all 24 permutations and
let's actually
is of interest to people in in uh in uh
in working actually in big data and in
statistics and this is actually how we
discovered that connection because we
noticed that one of our one of the
papers in that area actually cites our
paper and we we look what what we're
exactly saying and we also know that
they say this results
and uh maybe
let me let me skip this this result but
so so do we so the question is do we
need all 24 permutations and the answer
is no we can go with eight elements set
and I will present that on the next
slide but uh
but let me say that the current record
is actually six permutations which was
proven recently by John Noel and two
students of his plural and Dukes so we
have a they have a set of six
permutations but notice that here I am
saying they have an eight element set of
four point permutations but these
permutations are not of order for they
have mixed orders
and for the lower bound
there's a paper of Martin qureshka a
student of mine which we who actually
showed and again using like analytic
methods by by studying like the the
perturbations of the of the uniform
measure that uh that one would need at
least four permutations so if one wants
to have a set of permutation such that
everyone looks at the permuton and the
density of these permutations are what
they should be when by and and this
would imply that the measure is uniform
when vet said must have at least four
elements and even if one allows mixing
the orders
so the the general boundary one allows
mixing the orders is foreign the answer
would be between four and six if one
wants to have a subset of of 1 over 24
when the answer will be between 4 and 8.
so let me show you some of these sets
and we actually and again we were like
looking at the at the permuton and
studying like the like perturbations and
so on so we were actually looking at a
slightly more general question so
instead of looking at the density of
every permutation in in the set if we're
looking at the sum of the densities
and we show we actually characterize all
subsets of four-point permutations that
are forcing positive Randomness in this
stronger sense so these are the the
three eight element ones this one is the
12 element ones of course if this one is
forcing quasi random result or
complement as well because if if the
density if the sum of the densities of
these eight permutation is one third of
some of the complementary the densities
of the the remaining permutation must be
two thirds so so so so the
characterization goes but uh that uh a
set a subset of uh of Four Element
permutation force is quasi Randomness
and this is some forcing uh way if and
only if it is one of these four sets or
it's symmetric to it it's meaning like
it's uh it's rotational asymmetric or
it's it's complement it's a complement
over
and uh and uh even Ivan would require
instead of looking at the sum looking at
the density of each of the permutations
individually no no said no no smaller
studies known to before
and I think I still have like five
minutes
so so I am allowed to speak about Latin
squares
so so we all know what is a Latin Square
so a Latin square is just a matrix in v
in every row and every column there's a
permutation of numbers from 1 to n
and one can define a
a sub pattern density which would be
defined by by saying okay I select some
some columns some rows so let's say I
select the the second column and the
third column second and the fourth row
which means I'm picking up these four
elements and I just look again at the
relative densities and this gives me
that this is one this is two this is
three and this is four some of them
might be actually equal in which case I
guess get two equal numbers but if I
have a large randomly selected latent
Square when uh when this this happens
with with a small probability it also
more precisely even more or more
strongly even for for a fixed lightning
Square this happens with a small
probability divided by figure random
subset of rows and columns I will see
the the same element
so I can ignore those patterns so this
is the definition of pattern density and
there's a limit Theory which is actually
somewhat non-trivial for various reasons
so first of all one needs to come up
with the right notion of regularity
partitions which is actually less tricky
and when more importantly one needs to
sell to when one when one has a limit
object like arguing but actually for
every limit object there is actually a
sequence of latency is converging to it
when this is this is the the non-trivial
part and and one is the the recent
powerful results on the existence of the
designs you do key wash to actually do
this this template so the limit theory
was developed by by Frederick Garber
Robert Hancock Honda
and they asked like whether there's a
similar characterization of Quasi
Randomness as in the for other company
apparel structures in particular like if
everyone can just look at the at
patterns of uh first of all finitely
many patterns or patterns of of some
small sizes such that if their densities
are what they should be when this would
imply to cross the random numbers
so this is this is the question or a
conjecture so does there exist or where
X is K and L such that the the the
sequence of of letting square is quasi
random even only if the density of every
K times L pattern K is let's say the
number of rows and L is the number of
columns converges to 1 over k l
factorial
because there's a there's a there's a
there's a red five
which doesn't appear on the right yeah
so yeah so no credit so I answered your
question on the mic so those who follows
remotely so the question is about how
how the the sampling is defined or the
more precisely the sub pattern or
patterns are defined so one so so what I
understand mostly when one select some
colors and rows so so once I like some
colors and some of the rows okay so so I
have chosen here the the second column
and the First Column the second round
and the fourth row so so now I am
looking in this case in the square and
more General I will be looking at the
rectangle and I am looking for elements
I do see where and when I read them
similarly to the patterns according to
where all this so the smallest one will
be one the second smallest which is this
string will become two the first mod is
will become 3 and the larger will become
forms and uh
so it's it's not a Latin square and even
more generally like even has a sequence
of Latin squares when the densities of
those that do actually repeat a number
will go to zero so so one the limit
densities will be non-zero only for both
where all these in general attacks and
potatoes and alkalbots all these K times
L numbers are distinct
and because the if I have a huge Latin
Square the probability that I will hit
like two entries which are which have
the same value goes into limit to zero
so so the densities of the patterns that
are of Interest are only those where all
these numbers are are different so we're
very non-latin squares actually they're
more like some kind of generalized
two-dimensional permutations and the the
conjecture of uh of uh of Frederick
Robertson and Mariam who developed the
limit theory for for Latin Square wall
so that was a finite characterization
but when X is K and L such that if the
density of those patterns that have the
right to be non-zero is what it should
be in a truly in a sequence of kind of
truly random Latin scores when the the
corresponding limit object will be the
uniform I don't want to say it will be
like equal everywhere to something
because it's somewhat complex object I
intentionally didn't Define it but when
this will capture the question
right yes
yes and this is the result
so so using the their theory of of
limits of medicine we actually showed
that it's enough to take K to be 2 and L
to be free so so if one chance looks
like the rectangles two times three and
the density or the patterns two times
three and the density of each pattern
goes to one over 720 when
the density of every KL pattern which
does not repeat entries goes to 1 over
KL factorial so so this would imply that
directions
and uh and we also show that two times
three cannot be replaced it's one times
l or two times two so this is the best
possible so one option might be that one
decrease is one of the coordinates and
increases the other but it's not
possible and likewise like going to
decrease this three to two so we have
examples again using the like we we
didn't construct like it we construct
the the limit objects explicitly but we
didn't construct the the latents because
we just accused the sampling result
so and I think I just ran out of time so
I presented various results on on classy
random combinator objects that was
proven using the the methods from the
from the theory of combinator limits and
there were plenty of open problems my
favorite is clearly finding the smallest
project random forcing set of
permutations
and let me just thank you for your
attention
thanks very nice talk so yeah questions
so
um as was pointed out by Jansen diaconis
uh the results of low fast and security
actually fall off from an old result of
idols and Huda Hoover and in general
they have this nice uh view of graph
limits as a question of a sampling
question in statistics so do these other
Notions which you mentioned can they
formulate it instead of talking about a
continuous graph and talking about some
probability measurements and infinite
combinatorial object so to some extent
one would say the limit of a sequence of
graphs should be in infinite graphs
that's false but actually Iris Hoover
says the limit of a sequence of graphs
is a random infinite graph and so is
there some similar notion for your
latent squares it's the limit of latent
squares somehow an infinite random
letter Square
the question is about like uh so I will
okay I'm not sure I can reformulate the
question to repeat oh no you had a mic
so I don't have to actually so everybody
so I would be thinking so so my
impression is that the best or clearly a
freedom in choosing these limit objects
so I would be be thinking the answer is
yes just by that one there are very
different views on on the on the
computer objects like where all these
limit objects like the graph phones and
the and the these these early results
you mentioned and I would think that's
the that would be the same for for
lighting Express in particle like the
the the object but uh and I mean if I
somehow
uh oversimplify it it's more or less
like a graph if all that set of vertices
so and colored edges so basically it's
actually very similar to to like in some
Spirit to to graph limits
a question which
so you could so your infinite object for
the Latin squares you set allows you to
generate a sequence of Latin squares
is there some way to formulating when
this
sequence so far for sequences of random
graphs we know that if the exchangeable
then this corresponds to a graph one
it's a similar notion of exchangeability
for
these latent squares which would allow
you to say it corresponds to a graphene
so I would be so so the short answer is
there is not but I would be surprised if
you cannot like develop it in the
analogous way
so of course like I might not be
overlooking some technical detail but I
would believe that it should I mean it's
so close to two graphs but I would be
surprised if that's really a problem
I have a question that I'm in for
farmingtons I mean our Communications or
Latin squares we have a now notion of
glossary Randomness so a next question
would be like do you have a notion of
regularity there yes yes you do so so
yes so so actually all these uh these
limit objects like at least if I'm
coming more from the combinatorial side
like kind of at least I view where I'm
like uh as a combinator as kind of
limits of regularity partitions and
that's the case in in permutations
there's like the regularity due to
Cooper which is actually different
Cooper vendor Cooper in the in the in
the Latin Square results uh tournaments
and you do the same for as for graphs
and uh I don't think that and there is a
notion of regularity and you can for
example for a sequence I mean for a
permutation so you can have you have
also a regularity Lemma kind of thing
yeah you can yeah so extract
subsequences and say that all our quasi
random except a small part
yeah
um
so so actually the notion of regularity
for permutations is conceptually simple
one for graphs I see so so one doesn't
get the irregular pairs for example okay
and uh
uh and there's also like uh Associated
removal Ms so there might be some tricky
bits in times like if you have a removal
Lemma how you measure the distance
because there might be like uh various
uh various metrics on on permutations
like how to say what two permutations
are close to each other but uh but I
would believe that in even in the
like like
they might be like when you kind of
compare how like kind of the the more
like I don't know whether I would say L1
Norm but somehow like visually or you
may do like more combinatorial ones like
looking at the number of transpositions
needed to transform one permutation to
to another this will actually give
slightly different metrics but even for
the stronger ones wherever Associated
removal I must although the fury much
stronger than so in this this direction
the theory has been I see has been
developed thanks
so just two small questions the first
one is related to this all this Hoover
stuff so uh you know as was mentioned
you know all this Hoover basically say
is that the whole graph on stuff is
related to exchangeable uh array of
random variables and so um the Quasi
random stuff for Chung Liu at all uh
basically you can think of this as what
properties about uh moments do does this
imply that you have a unique
distribution for this infinite family of
exchangeable kind of variables and so
um so sort of uh what so the question is
do your results maybe they basically
give you structural properties about
exchangeable family of random variables
so if you have these properties of the
moments of exchangeable families of
random variables this implies you
uniquely know the distribution
I mean and the question is the other way
are there results from the family of
exchangeable arrays that imply your
results
you know like there's method of moments
in uh in statistic probability which
asks what about under what conditions do
moments uniquely determine the
distribution
and your first set of results seem to
imply this sort of relationship if you
know these things about exchangeability
then this implies uh uniqueness of
distributions so so I would uh so first
of all for most of the the graph forms
or like other limits like there's no
like chance to to like describe and buy
finitely many many
variables so so I would be thinking but
the general answer would be no but in
some particular cases the answer would
be S and I would slightly prefer having
this question offline in particular
because somehow it's getting on the
boundary of my expertise I assume the
talk is recorded and I don't want to say
something yeah
okay so then the second question this is
you don't have to answer but uh so you
know like going to your permutation
maybe the next slide yeah so that
question you know under what conditions
do you have uh do you have uniform
distribution convergence to permutation
sort of a sort of related question is
suppose now you know not just
convergence like one over K factorial
but you know the rate at which something
converges so D you know you have a
sequence of permutations but D Pi comma
Pi I minus one over K factorial or the
total variation distance is like 1 over
square root n then do you get even more
results so for example can you say that
the distribution of permutations of
length one over log n is also like one
over log in factorial
and so
this is something that I guess uh with
with uh Suman here we have thought about
this for um graphons you know suppose in
the Chung Lou Graham
um setup suppose you know not just
things converge to P Squared Etc but you
also know rates of convergence then does
that imply for example existence of
cliques of size login
yeah so so I uh it's a it's an very
interesting question I don't think that
this has been at least I'm not a varied
has been studied for for permutations
like I would assume that you can like
using the techniques which exist for for
graphs and graph phones but like can
maybe one should be able to obtain some
results but I don't know like two to
what extent okay thank you
so maybe in the interest of time we can
end here and go to the coffee break uh
yeah and then let's thank the speaker